géraldine maillet on a vu dans une
interview pour tv mag vous avait révélé
avoir été menacé de mort pour vos
différentes prises de position dans tpm
paix et thierry beccaro me disais aussi
à la pub que lui aussi il avait eu des
menaces de mort regarder petit
récapitulatif sur gérald c'est une
révélation surprenante que géraldine
maillet a confié à tv mag puisqu'il
révèle avoir été menacé de mort suite à
certains de ses propos dans tpm pays à
quelques fois des thèmes qui m'ont valu
soit des menaces de mort sur les réseaux
sociaux
j'ai dû même porté plainte déposé une
main courante
plus grave encore sa fille a également
été visé par ces menaces on a menacé ma
fier tout ça ça a été très très chaud
pour moi ça a été vraiment très violent
vraiment j'ai été très peur on cause ses
prises de position dans l'émission
également dans une période plus
difficile pour la france où les tensions
étaient vives autour du mouvement des
gilet jaune si ces attaques ont été très
difficiles pour elle aujourd'hui
géraldine maillet a décidé de passer
outre et ne compte pas changer sa façon
de s'exprimer
j'essaie de dire ce que je pense avec
mon coeur avec la sincérité sans doute
avec aussi ma maladresse avec ma
brutalité je n'ai pas la science infuse
mais en tout cas j'essaie de dire ce que
je pense être
alors j'invite c'est vrai que nous ça
nous aviez déjà parlé un petit peu ici
mais c'est vrai qu'on pensait pas que
c'était à ce point là voilà c'est c'est
quoi ça vous vous a vraiment entendu
vous étiez vraiment triste voilà de tout
ce que vous receviez sur les réseaux
sociaux mais disons que tpm paix est une
émission très populaire relayé très
commentée donc forcément ses prises de
parole en direct tous les soirs sans
parfois accidentogène puisque j'ai
toujours pris le pari grâce à la liberté
que vous ne laissez de dire ce que je
pense sur des sujets plus ou moins
clivant j'avais eu peur des moments et
whipper à partir du moment où on a
identifié le nom ma fille sur les
réseaux sociaux exemple vous a envoyé
quoi en fait sur les réseaux bas on va
l'enlever on va être de jeu pas on va
trancher la gorge
à la suite de quelle prise de position
en fait il ya trois il ya deux gros ce
sujet ben je pense qu'on ait beaucoup
concernés autour de la table mais il ya
dessus
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya deux
thèmes qu'on ne peut pas aborder
sereinement et de manière apaisée en
france c'est tout ce qui concerne
l'islam en général on est soit
islamo-gauchiste soit islamophobe et on
ne supporte pas la nuance est la nuance
n'existe pas le sujet les sujets des
gilet jaune l'année dernière on était
très compliqué aussi
à partir du moment où on était contre on
est enfin on était forcément nantis
bourgeois insupportable et donc ça ne
pouvait pas non plus supporter la nuance
alors qu'on pouvait par exemple
défendent jacqueline gourault d'un côté
et critiquer certaines certaines actions
par ailleurs d'aidé gilet jaune
donc oui j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait des
thèmes des thèmes compliqué qui
hystérise complètement fin qui sont en
fait t'es pmp le reflet de la société
française aujourd'hui donc et amélie
sont les avis sont les bienvenus vous
savez voilà moi j'ai soumis les gilet
jaune à l'honneur et même si vous étiez
contre parfois j'ai fait quand même
essayer de ramener une discussion tous
mes [ __ ] les réseaux sociaux
finalement tout ça sous couvert
d'anonymat
et c'est ça qu'il faut vraiment dénoncer
c'est l'anonymat la la lâcheté vous avez
pensé arrêter l'émission moment un
moment donné oui je me suis dit qu'il
fallait arrêter parce que c'était un peu
trop moi cette médiatisation comme ça
pour moi c'était un peu aussi nouveau
grâce à vous aussi depuis quatre ans
c'est vrai on est on
sous les feux de la rampe mais mais je
me suis dit que non en fait il fallait
toujours gardé cette liberté ton dire ce
qu'on pensait toujours coûte que coûte
et que est d'accord ça alors non il ya
un nouveau un nouveau débat alors là qui
est complètement dingue c'est zéro vous
a reçu à nouveau des menaces de mort et
le féminisme
alors là il avait dit steris
complètement les chiennes de garde la
postmodern à 210 tirs etc en rut
alors là quand on dirait qu'on prenait
des positions assez tranché oui mais pas
vous êtes anti féministe oui
certainement pas voilà et non mais c'est
vrai que vous avez pris des positions
très tranchées dernièrement il faut
nuancer par exemple les problèmes de
balance t'emporte et tout ça et du coup
on est donc vous avez reçu des menaces
oui des menaces aussi doit vraiment sur
quoi on souhaite que tu sois violé sa le
saldanha pour savoir ce que c'est
exactement ou tabasser donc en fait
voilà c'est juste la folie tout ça sous
couvert de l'anonymat donc d'une grande
lâcheté
après tout va bien je suis une grande
fille et je sais mais pour quand même
vrai que j'adore